bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france donc on l'a dit
palette de l'état pour les restaurateurs
qui ne jouent pas le jeu en tout cas
c'est ce qu'a annoncé bruno le maire que
pensez vous de cette de cette annonce
bonjour bah écoutez
je pense que l'état a fait beaucoup pour
notre profession 1 depuis depuis des
mois on s'est battu justement pour que
pour qu'on soit reconnu comme une
profession quand même énormément
stigmatisés et qu'on ne pouvait pas nous
laisser sur le sur le côté là j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer donc
gabriel attal la semaine passée qui est
descendu à nice j'ai également rencontré
le ministre des tpe des pme nous leur
avons fait part de nos inquiétudes par
rapport justement à ce passe sanitaires
et notamment par rapport aux baisses de
chiffre d'affaires
la seule réponse qu'on a eu la seule
certitude qu'on a vu c'est que l'état
continuerait à nous accompagner si nous
jouions le jeu et si nous faisions ce
qu'ils avaient à faire donc totalement
contrôlé contrôler nos clients donc je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas on peut
pas dire qu'on a été abandonnée on va
pas dire que l'on va commencer à crier
sur le gouvernement à partir du moment
où on respecte les règles et en tout cas
nous c'est ce que nous préconisons
respecter les règles et contrôler nos
clients on sait que l'on sait que l'etat
sera d'ailleurs donc je les personnes
qui ne veulent pas
aujourd'hui contrôler leurs clients
sciemment se mêlent se met en porte à
faux et se mettent en grand danger
économique voilà donc vous comprenez
cette déclaration de bruno le maire qui
disait aussi c'est le contribuable
français qui finance le fonds solidarité
alors je ne vois pas comment expliquer
aux contribuables qu'il va financer des
gens qui trichent ce sont des tricheurs
c'est ces restaurateurs qui ne contrôle
pas ses passes élitaire goethe en stage
sont des tricheurs ce sont des gens qui
au moment qu'on leur demande plus plus
plus à chaque fois je peux comprendre je
peux comprendre leur désarroi maintenant
il faut il faut être clair est-ce qu'on
veut est-ce qu'on veut passer outre
cette épidémie est ce qu'on veut se
diront mais voilà ce sera plus qu'un
mauvais souvenir ou est-ce qu'on veut
encore avoir à fermer nos commerces on
se bat pour ne pas avoir à fermer parce
que ça a été très compliqué vous
imaginez bien onze mois de fermeture sur
quasiment de deux ans sur deux saisons
c'est très très compliqué à gérer malgré
les aime parce qu'on s'est pas enrichi
pendre avec les aides on est on a
simplement pu tenir la tête hors de
l'eau donc je te comprends que les gens
soient énervés maintenant les
applications pour le pass ont été
modifiés il faut même pas 5 secondes
pour contrôler des personnes je pense
qu'il faut qu'on fasse aussi à preuve de
un petit peu de bonne foi et qu'on
essaye de faire avancer les choses pour
qu'on puisse sortir de ce cauchemar si
si c'est la solution j'espère simplement
que c'est la solution aujourd'hui j'ai
en tout cas nous on pense que c'est la
solution de d'abord un tas sanitaires
pour que pour pouvoir continuer à
travailler tranquillement quand vous ne
rencontrez pas de difficultés
particulières lors du contrôle des
passagers terre
ont pensé non parce qu'on pensait on
pensait rencontrer franchement et puis
on s'est rendu compte que finalement au
final les balles et les clients jouent
le jeu alors énormément pour les
étrangers nous nous sommes à nice ici
dont nous avons une grosse clientèle
étrangère pendant les vacances donc au
final les gens jouent le jeu les gens
l'ont souvent sur eux et
il n'y a pas plus de problèmes que ça
alors évidemment vous avez des gens qui
sont excédés par rapport à ça mais on
n'y est pour rien on est on est
simplement là excuse excusez moi on est
on est simplement là pour pour appliquer
les consignes les consignes du
gouvernement donc voilà je pense
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde dans la
grande majorité joue le jeu et présente
son passe sans problème après je vous
dis pas qu'il ya pas une baisse de
chiffre d'affaires parce qu'il ya une
baisse conséquente du chiffre d'affaires
encore plus conséquente compte justement
il va y avoir sept cette réunion des
professionnels concernés ce sera le 30
août le but est donc d'évaluer secteur
par secteur le chiffre d'affaires
enregistré malgré les restrictions
sanitaires avaient très vite quelles
évolutions quelles évolutions enfin vous
pouvez le constater comme vous êtes
aussi gérant d'un restaurant mais quelle
évolution à ce chiffre d'affaires alors
nous nous conte ce que je peux
rencontrer ainsi sur l'ensemble de la
profession c'est à dire qu'il ya
vraiment des disparités énormes entre
les gens qui travaillent sur des pôles
touristiques sur des zones de gros
afflux touristique ou yahoo il ya
quasiment pas de baisse ou très peu de
baisses et sur des zones où on travaille
avec des clients tels plutôt local avec
des habitués et là il ya vraiment de
grosses disparités avec des grosses
baisses de chiffre d'affaires qui
peuvent monter jusqu'à 50 % donc de
toutes façons le ministre à la grise il
a brisé le ministre les tpe des pme
nous a assuré qu'il y allait avoir une
clause de revoyure notamment donc à la
fin août pour qu'on fasse le point sur
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
pour voir ce qu'il allait en être du
fonds de solidarité parce que vous
imaginez bien que la situation a changé
le fonds de solidarité avait été prévu
pour pour la deuxième vague on en est à
la quatrième donc évidemment il y aura
une clause de revoyure par rapport à ça
notre seule inquiétude nous c'est de
savoir que l'etat sera présent parce
qu'ils ont nui déjà beaucoup d'argent
sur la table pour aider les entreprises
c'est l'argent du contribuable d'accord
et nous ce qu'on essaie de faire passer
comme message c'est que vous avez mis
beaucoup d'argent
s'il faut remettre encore un petit peu
pour qu'on arrive à passer tout ça il
faut continuer à être présent pour les
entreprises il faut continuer à nous
accompagner et nous de notre côté je
pense qu'il faut qu'on joue le jeu il
faut qu'on contrôle qu'on contrôle nos
clients pour faire en sorte que
l'épidémie puisse puisse sortir de 2,5
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes vice-président de
l'union des métiers et des industries de
l'hôtellerie des alpes-maritimes et
fiable merci à vous